good morning John Happy New Year it's a
time for reflecting on the year that has
passed and hoping for a good one to come
but also as I am incapable of not doing
asking why why is it this way
why January first and if it's gonna be
January first why isn't January first on
the Solstice well I will give you a hint
this monumental modern institution of
our calendar and the way that it works
and begins has to do with three people
who you have never heard of the earth
travels around the Sun in a circle and
there is no beginning or end to a circle
what I have a beginning of the year I
get that and basically we have
traditionally just picked one and
different cultures have picked different
dates for different reasons and they
turn out to be really interesting and
complicated reasons complicated enough
that I can only really talk about one
and I'm gonna pick the one that I'm most
familiar with so let's go back in time
to 46 BC Julius Caesar has just become
the first emperor of Rome and the
calendar is a mess it's based on this
calendar that's hundreds of years old
that started out having only ten months
with December being the last month and
March being the first month and it's a
lunar calendar every month begins with a
new moon there's a full moon in the
middle and then it ends again with a new
moon since the lunar calendar and the
solar calendar don't line up they had to
have some way of getting realigned each
year in that system and I'm not kidding
here was 51 days of unaffiliated buffer
time that occurred between December and
March that just weren't inside of any
month but in the 700s BC one of the
original kings of Rome and Numa
Pompilius one of the guys you haven't
heard of decided this system just wasn't
gonna cut it
so we added two new months to the
beginning of the year you've heard of
them January and February has resulted
in a number of months having Latin
prefixes that no longer aligned with
their position in the year which is an
immense source of frustration for me but
that is when January first became the
first day of the new year in Rome
weirdly though January 1st kept falling
on what we would consider different days
because the behavior of the moon and the
behavior of the Sun kept not having
anything to do with each other so in
order to keep the summer months
happening in the summer they had to keep
messing with the number of days and each
month and then they would have to add
extra months sometimes it was super
confused Julius Caesar like any good
dictator wanted to establish some dang
order consulted an Alexandrian
astronomer named genies who
suggested that they scrapped the lunar
calendar completely in favor of a solar
calendar like the ones with the recently
Concord Egyptians has sicinius had
calculated that the solar year was
365.25 days so he suggested a year 365
days along with an extra day thrown in
every four years during the shortest
month February probably sounds familiar
to you Caesar now have the opportunity
to establish when January first would
appear on the solar calendar and he
could have picked the Solstice as one
last final shoutout to the lunar
calendar he put it on the new moon that
was closest to the Solstice which just
happened to be about nine days later so
yes the date of a new moon in 45 BC
decided when January first would appear
on the solar calendar kinda because the
solar year is actually slightly shorter
than 365 point two five days the drift
began again by the Middle Ages people
were confused enough that they were
basically celebrating the new year
whenever they felt like until 1582 when
Pope Gregory the thirteenth consulted
with an Italian astronomer Aloisius
lilius the last guy you haven't heard of
proposed to Pope Gregory a solution for
these drifting days a slight
modification of the leap year schedule
having only 97 leap years every four
hundred years instead of a hundred every
four hundred years Gregory then
instituted and mandated this new
calendar which we called the Gregorian
calendar and we still basically use
today the Numa Pompilius so Sydney's
Aloisius lilius thank you very much for
your contributions to our world today
I'm sorry everybody's forgotten about
you but here we are now John celebrating
those people entering the year 2016 our
tenth year of vlogging on YouTube Wow
what super interested to see people's
comments on your last video but I felt
like that was extraordinarily
unscientific and we weren't getting good
data so I've set up an actual survey
that people can take as a link in the
description if you want to answer some
questions about what we should do in the
next year here on vlogbrothers John
thanks for being a great brother thanks
for another great year and I'll see you
on Tuesday